das problem ist in der kosmetikbranche
sogar noch größer als in der
tabakindustrie sie sprechen von
tausenden verschiedenen chemikalien
deren einsatz nicht besser kontrollieren
endet das in einer katastrophe manches
davon könnte millionen kinder schädigen
noch bevor wir es für wichtig oder
ungiftig erklären
punkte werden mit problemen bei der
fortpflanzung in verbindung gebracht mit
eierstockkrebs frühgeburten
quecksilbervergiftung hormonaktiven
substanzen
[Musik]
wollen nicht noch 60 jahre warten um
dann zu erfahren dass der stoff in
unserer handcreme brustkrebs verursacht
chemikalien sind nicht unschuldig bis
man das gegenteil beweist